[Music]
it's such an unbelievably intimate film
I mean the the the story itself the
performances the the way you filmed it
um Michelle just to start I'd love to
hear you talk about when you first began
the writing process on this what was
what was like the first element that you
were working with was it somebody
dealing with Dementia was it the
Sylvia's character with a particular
traumatic background she had what what
was your entry well thank you first of
all and thanks everyone I strangely had
the Point of Departure was the scene
where he's following her uh the class
reunion I don't know why but I I thought
a class reunion and he follows her home
and then I started wondering who is she
and who is you know what what's going on
uh and I at first I thought that he was
guilty of you know that that he would
follow her because he he actually did uh
what she accuses him of um and it was
going to be a Revenge kind of you know
drama and then I changed my mind uh my
sister challenged me said come on you've
done that kind of movies before you can
do better
uh and yeah
I and you
did well and and and I was at a moment
in my life where I was in a more
peaceful moment and it made more sense
to write it this way and I'm interested
in broken people that's been in most of
my films uh the film starts at the AA
meeting and and
and the place where where Sylvia Works
uh you know I I'm I'm interested in in
shining a light on people that's
normally that are normally ignored both
in life and on
Cinema um one of the really remarkable
things to me about this film is you
create um it's not just a f well the the
the sense of family of family
relationships with the the teenage
daughter with the the mother with just
the whole family constellation is so
fully realized and beautifully done um
could you maybe talk a bit about the
casting process starting with how you
got these two incredible performers um
but then how you built out the rest of
the cast uh and especially because of
the way I shoot uh you know with no
coverage and all that if I if I don't
have fantastic actors on every scene and
for every role no matter how small the
role is um it's not going to be good um
uh I was I never dreamed of having such
great actors uh it started with
Jessica our agents did a good job at
putting us together uh I yeah I I always
okay I'll shut up but no no no come on
no no no I was I'll shut
up uh but they were good yeah yeah they
they put us together and we had a zoom
uh meeting Jessica and I and
I I never want my I I always want to
make the next movie sooner than later
and I was ready to shoot so I'm like oh
Jessica chain she's gonna waste my time
you know like you know do I really need
a Hollywood star to you know so they
tell me she read the script she likes it
a lot she watch your movies like relax
you know so I I don't relax we have the
zoom meeting and I'm like are you sure
you want to do this yes you know there's
no trailer no money no nothing yes I
want to do it I I know what an
independent film is you know and yeah it
all worked out and then I asked Jessica
who would you like to work with uh
because I knew that the chemistry on
screen is everything I mean once I took
the challenge of of not making the worst
possible story and making a romantic
movie to my only
surprise uh yeah I never thought I was
going to make a romantic
movie um you need chemistry and how do
you do that so Jessica said that Peter's
one of the actors she always wanted to
work with and and then the my casting
director Susan shopmaker she's really
fantastic I trust her a big deal and I
in mered Weaver and Jessica Harper and
uh Josh char Char El F sure it's it's a
great cast yeah Jessica I'd love to hear
well from both of you starting with you
Jessica when you first got the script
what was it that appealed to you in it
and and was it more or less this story
was the script fully formed by that
point uh when I first read the script it
was working with Michelle that was uh
what was the most appealing I mean
before I even read the script and then
as I started going through it I was so
blown away that it was this
story that I thought could really go
into um this idea of like okay this was
written in response to the me movement
it's a Revenge film uh she's going to
take revenge on all these men you know
that have you I kind of like and then
that didn't happen and then um I thought
at the end maybe she'd find out he
really did it it'd be like a
thriller and then that didn't happen
and I realized uh I mean I I knew this
because Michelle is such an incredible
filmmaker i' seen his films but it was
uh another lesson to me of of
how special he is as a creative because
he doesn't go down um an obvious cliche
path and just when I thought you know I
had an idea of what he would write it it
he surprised me on every step of the way
I mean it's guess it is a film who knows
if you even thought about this in
response to me to movement but it's also
a film about
healing and how beautiful that that's
the rebellious
Choice um in a industry that doesn't
necessarily make that
choice Peter when you so you came to
this on Jessica's recommendation but
when you read the script what was your
uh what was
your uh
m j Jessica through yeah I no I I did
obviously want to work with Peter but
his career is of course and we got
together yeah yeah I would say it's it's
nice that I didn't know that I had been
recommended by her because you know when
actors come together and she had just
won an Academy Award and you know what
you want to do when two actors come
together is that the power Dynamic be
relevant to the story and that's one
thing that Jessica did just like
immediately this woman had just won the
Academy Award literally and stepped into
this environment and it was entirely
about where these two people related to
each other right so anything extraneous
like that you always kind of
want compartmentalized somewhere and I
learned about it at Venice and I'm of
course extremely grateful because
I think it is definitely a different
kind of part that I'm normally offered I
know that it
is and um maybe it takes a fellow actor
to to bring that out I'm really really
thankful and and also a
foreigner because I heard it wasn't your
idea
though so we got together and we started
walking around and talking and I showed
you my belly to show you that I had no
six-pack yeah I I I told him I I don't
want cuz cuz I I I knew that you know
he's running marathons and stuff so I
was like I I want this guy's soul to be
real you know I don't want him to have
like a six-pack and Peter goes
like here's my
belly no I was like in the worst
physical shape that I really had ever
been in I had I had uh herniated a disc
like a year before and when I came to
him I remember walking down the street
and if you've ever hurt your back like
that you know a back problem is a full
body problem and my right leg wouldn't
go as far forward as my left leg when I
walked so I would have have to make this
one take little baby steps and then I
was like that guy from The carber Nut
Show um oh come on help
me um
yeah there there's something great about
being allowed to just Embrace where you
are physically mentally whatever and
when you work with someone like Michelle
it is such a collaboration that he wants
you exactly where you are in your life
and to bring that into the story you
know Peter could you talk a bit about
how you sort of worked with the dementia
and found that in your perfor in your
performance because I thought it was so
beautifully and UND so done with such
understatement it felt very real but you
weren't playing the dementia I mean yeah
well
um it was very important to me that it
be a story about this man and not
dementia you know um and I do think we
have a habit of in Even in our own lives
is my uncle had dementia and um you know
the day before he was diagnosed we just
thought he was being annoying a lot of
the time and not remembering things and
we tease him about it and stuff and then
we heard he had dementia and then we
started treating him like a sick
person
and I didn't want to treat this
character like a sick person I wanted to
give him every chance that I could to
have the most life that I could give him
and um and I do think it's just an
obstacle and and he's at the beginning
of his journey and a lot of the people
in the movie like like the people that
relate to her character like the people
in her life are
going trauma scary irritating stop
talking about the same thing and the
people in my life are like give me the
keys to the car you're not allowed to go
outside I mean clearly this guy can walk
down a sidewalk by himself on some level
I mean in dementia is not a even thing
right you have episodes and then things
get a little better um
so it was very important for me to play
it realistically by what I experienced
in my own life by people I talk to
because um I think that it's important
that we as a society think of them not
as oh so and so is a schizophrenic or so
and so's demented he has dementia but
that that's so and so who is Gary who
schizophrenic Bob who happens to have
dementia um let people retain their
dignity to the last possible
moment I thought
um the film has so much intimacy I mean
especially between the two of you and a
lot of that I felt I mean it came from
both of you but I felt like the dementia
LED you to be I was watching you be
present you you were completely present
for Sylvia or Jessica I felt like in so
many of the scenes you're just being
with her there's cuz you you have no I
mean you have a past but you just felt
very much in the moment with her
responding to exactly what was happening
in that moment which was really
beautiful to watch it it's you can only
do it if it's you're doing it back and
forth obviously I mean I've been very
present on a lot of movie sets where
nobody
noticed it's
lonely um Jessica I also wanted to ask
um uh I'm not familiar with the
performer who played your daughter uh
absolutely
incredible um your scenes with her your
scenes with Meritt Weaver amazing and
we'll get to your mom in a moment but um
terrifying but could you talk about I
mean I'd love to hear you talk about um
right the the relationship with your
daughter felt so real and the there
there was an ease between the two of you
and all the different colors that go
into a relationship you mother daughter
teenager relationship um could you talk
about how you worked on that with her
and and what that process was
like this was a very strange um uh film
for me and process for me because it's
unlike anything I've really ever done
before normally I work quite a bit with
the other actors before we start
shooting and go go through Back stories
and do all of those things but on this
project I really did it on my own you
know Sylvia is so
solitary in in everything that that how
she walks through the world even with
her daughter I mean it's clear that she
has something but she hasn't shared
really who she is with her daughter and
she doesn't really share who she is with
anyone until she meets
Saul um so we I had met
Brooke uh with Michelle and we had a
meal together but I was quite removed
from everyone and I found and I didn't
again I didn't do it on purpose but I
found it
made them seek me out more in the way
that they would see try to seek out
Sylvia to try to get like to she's imp
penetrable and try to like understand
what was going on with her I really I
would come to set and not really talk to
anyone and I'm not I'm really not like
that I I would say hello and then I
would just disappear and with us every
every time we spoke it was when the
camera was rolling and we shot in
chronological order so it was building
the relationship between the two of them
and I really didn't know Peter but I got
to know him when the camera was rolling
through what we were doing and same with
Meritt I mean from the very first moment
with her I just felt so she's so genius
at what she does because she plays the
scenes with such kindness but at the
same time I just felt so judged and so
shamed every time I was in a room with
her and you know Olivia and
Sylvia so it was I didn't work with them
and Brook on creating this shared
history because I thought it was so
important that Sylvia be removed from it
and Brooke man what a great actress
because there were a lot of scenes that
Michelle would ask us to play with we
would shoot the scenes but then he would
he would add things and and I would
challenge her a bit and she just really
came back every every moment she was so
fantastic to work
with I that's amazing to hear I mean I
definitely get the sense of remove of
your character of course throughout but
there's such a sense of lived reality to
that family it's amazing to hear your
what you just said about sort of what
the process was like um wow
um um in the course of shooting in
chronological order did you um stay very
true to the script or were there moments
where you improvised or
or this SC was improvised the bathtub
scene yeah it was in the script it was a
a scene in a bed uhhuh and we spoke and
and you know wondered if there was
perhaps something different and it was
one take I mean we didn't know we didn't
really know what it was going to do
except I was going to be in the bathtub
crying and he'd come in and then we just
played the scene I think it was going to
take too long to dry that shirt off to
do it again one take done
Michelle I I'd love to hear you talk a
bit about um sort of as a director I
have some specific questions um about
how you how you shot it um for well a
number of questions but one I notice
there were some key scenes where you had
kind of a wide shot of a group of people
like the scene when they're playing
Monopoly the camera it's a long scene
that plays out with a single take the
camera's kind of low down close to the
board and you see so much happens in
that scene and it's amazing first of all
a dog walks through then there's kids so
you have animals and children but beyond
that there's like emotionally a lot
going on um and then the scene of course
when you come back and encounter your
mother for the first time I mean that
scene is I think a static camera just
taking in the whole thing and those are
like two of the most powerful scenes in
the movie and just could you talk about
your decision to do to shoot it shoot
them that way and sort of I don't know
did you do lots of takes of those or was
it what was your approach the game scene
the monopolis scene was kind of easy to
shoot I was lucky or to put it in better
words we we the casting was good the
kids were good everybody understood the
scene so it was kind of easy to shoot uh
and they found the Rhythm and what I
like about that scene is that the the
energy is very different before Sylvia
arrives it changes and it changes again
and it's almost like they were happy up
until Sylvia arrives and ruins the day
you know and and and and so so she's
always like but yeah it's so sad it's so
sad uh and everything is because they
they they've been especially the sister
uh not acknowledging what happened you
know to her I mean Sylvia is such a
beautiful character and enduring and
giving and she makes an effort every day
but she's mistreated on on a regular
bases and she's used to it so that scene
was easy to shoot there's two dogs
actually they belong to the house there
were the house dogs they were on the
script the one dog
um again Brook is the main element on
that scene the main actress I think the
way Brook she's such a mature actress
for her age uh for any age she's she's
amazing the other scene was trickier
because the monopo SC even if it
wouldn't have been good I could edit the
film without it but the other scene it
it it's a key scene that I was worried
about throughout the whole shooting like
yeah today was good but wait till we
shoot that scene if it's not good
there's no movie um we shot it from that
angle and then I do gotta say that
unlike in any other scene I shot several
angles I mean several for me like three
more
angles for me it's a
lot uh and we didn't use them I just
used uh Jessica Harper at the I mean we
use at the beginning to show that
they're that you know she comes into the
house and she realizes the mother is
there and but uh again the actors were
great great Jessica Harper was fantastic
at playing it from her back and and
moving around and getting in front of
Jessica cover almost covering from the
camera mered Weaver was amazing at you
know what she's doing with her hands
instinctively I I don't direct actors
that much I I trust actors I gave them a
lot of space to work and they react
they're great because of that I didn't
tell Peter stand behind Jessica that's
what Saul would have done and he knows
more about Soul than me so I trust the
actors a big deal uh but I was very
nervous that day and when we shot the
first or the second take we turned to
look at each other and we were like I
think we got it I think it's good I said
yes but still we're going to shoot it 10
more times and from different Ang
because I was I couldn't gamble but at
the end we used like the second take we
could have gone home early
yeah I never go home early was we would
have shot something else yeah I it's an
incredible scene I mean and it's almost
the same mangle we're showing the same
part of the house that house is so
uncomfortable for Sylvia every time she
goes there and what's also sad about the
confrontation scene is that this time
she goes with a new boyfriend like
teenagers and she's happy and it's the
first time that it should be nice and
then of course well but at the end it's
satisfying because what Meritt says I
remember it's a you know finally yeah
did um can you talk a bit more about I'm
sorry U I feel so bad I'm forgetting the
actress's name who plays the mom oh
Jessica Harper Jessica Harper I mean
she's Jessica
Harper susperia she's really scary um
but what struck me about she's honestly
she's Terri I I the first time she's
alone with your daughter I just felt oh
this is not good this is like I felt the
daughter was in pain apparel but but
she's also not playing her as a monster
she's a human being she's playing a
fully human approach to that role so I'm
just curious how what conversations you
had with her or did she just bring that
almost none I'll tell you how it was I I
saw a selfcast a self tape cast uh I I
never look at the names when I get self
tapes I just look at the tapes I don't
want to know who's who or what and you
know and I didn't recognize Jessica
because I had had seen her in a while I
remember her from Stardust Memories and
susperia but I I just saw this
actress she was amazing she did a
perfect you know I knew I I'm very lazy
as a director I don't want to direct
much the actors so just get the good
actors that will yeah and she's also
very clever then we had a long
conversation but she gave me all the
answers I she did it I gotta say
wow
lazy
um I'd also love to hear you talk a bit
about music namely the lack of score um
which I loved it's I mean your your
music was Whit or Shade of Pale right
was that was your music budget yeah
that's it that's that's it that's it was
that did you know that from the
beginning that you weren't going to
score or I wanted to play with the the
Mana more on an emotional level than a
logical level so when he follow follows
her I I think it works because it's more
emotional than logical and the music is
very important to make that work I pick
this song because it's a the the melody
is very powerful and nostalgic and
melancholic uh the Hammond is very it's
it's I I don't know what other song
could have worked like like so well uh
it evokes it's a very evocative song uh
um a very expensive song
too but there was no way around it there
was no way and and also what's great
about uh w a share of fail is that the
lyrics don't make any sense so because I
would never do that thing where on the
credits you're explaining oh this is a
love story you know you just saw la la
la it's like very I I respect the
audience a big deal to do that yeah so
wider share of pill I wanted it to
become part of the story I wanted to the
it's a very it's a different song each
time you hear it and at the end she's
listening to it which gives it a
different meaning of course and and also
some someone told me are you sure you
want to use in the story The the song
that was important for him with the wife
I'm like yeah I trust the audience you
know it doesn't have to be exclusively
their song I think when writer or
directors are take things in such a
literal literal way it's can be boring
you got to trust the audience
um lastly I want to ask all of you that
um I'm always curious about this what
the experience of seeing the film for a
first time with the with an audience
right especially with a film like this
I'm picturing your set being very closed
and uh intimate and and small crew and
then to um experience this with an
audience did did does the film play were
you surprised by how audiences reacted
to the film or did you have a a
surprised reaction to the film itself
when you saw it um bringing it out in
the world what's that been like for all
of
you I mean the the first time we
screened it at Venice it was like a
famous theater that was packed where
people clapped for eight minutes after
it was over people were crying it it was
like uh it was an ecstatic crazy big
reaction yeah so yeah I never
I was completely bowled over
um but I I also watched it
that for the first time that so I mean
I'd seen a cut of it but not he changed
it and
um it just I could feel how much it was
resonating with me with other people and
I thought great there's there's another
good one they don't come along that
often you know it's like time to crack
out the champagne
yeah yeah it was it was amazing to have
that experience of the film it did feel
for me and and I think I was sitting
between you guys just in this exact
position and that one it it felt almost
sometimes embarrassing because I had
seen the film
before um I hadn't seen it with other
people really and then like the the
confrontation scene was really hard to s
in the audience and I think I was just
kept saying to I hate her I hate her I
hate her I hate her I hate her I just
kept saying it like it was so difficult
I couldn't just sit and enjoy the film I
really felt
like I that scene is really tough for me
to watch and especially in that moment
it was really uh I just I mean I
couldn't just sit quietly and watch the
film you were I was freaking out yeah I
I can't look at her face anymore I know
she's a great
actress I hate
her that's how good she is well how do
how do you feel about the brother-in-law
I mean he was uh too he's pretty
horrible but he also didn't know I mean
listen I yeah the brother-in-law is
awful but mer even Meritt and she
finally tells the truth at the end but
there was years where she didn't like
even her telling the truth is the
Betrayal of like you couldn't have done
this sooner you know it's just feel it's
so tough this movie I think yeah I think
remind me if if if I'm wrong but the
scene where Brook confronts her when she
goes back to the house and tells her I
would never do that that wasn't scripted
right I mean I scripted yeah wrote it
you're a very good writer Michelle
Franco that must have been scripted
that's in it no I thought I wrote it
afterwards or something it was on the
script it's in the
scpt
it's all falling apart up
here that's a that's an amazing scene I
mean the the strength Brook brings to
that and it's so simple she's just
direct she's like well I would never do
that to my sister I mean that was
devastating BR very very good yeah and
Mer's amazing oh mer Mer's amazing she
yeah you feel in that scene that she's
also in some sense has been abused by
caring it
yeah Venice was fantastic then
Tiff Toronto was also great screening
that one was really fun yeah I got into
this habit of like coming you know for
these q&as I would come and just sit and
watch the last 30 minutes of the movie
uh you know because it's nice to be in
the same world that you guys are in and
at Tiff I I is like where I discovered
that it was comedic yeah you know maybe
it's because they're Canadian but and
they own they own comedy we all know
that but um no that would you know
different audiences reveal different
things about the movie to you if you sit
and watch it with
them well thank you all for being here
and thank you for this film I mean I
[Applause]
yeah
um I really do I I do want to say you're
Jessica and Peter you're I I mean it's
the work you do in this film is so
personal and intimate and it's like you
let us into this like I just wanted to
be with you the whole time and just
right you're sitting on the couch
watching a movie that you can't even
watch or you're walking down the
sidewalk and it's just like there's this
ease is for all the drama that's going
on and the the real pain that you're
both in there's just this ease where you
both welcome the audience in in a
beautiful way so thank you and thank you
Michelle thank you so much all right
thank you all thank you thank you all
for
[Music]
coming